phones are the the main way that people
access satellite navigation data
nowadays we have all sorts of other
receivers but this is what will tend to
have and so that's the illustration I'm
going to be using today there are
satellites up there your phone works out
where's one and it goes how far am i
from is it is it something like that
it's pretty much like that and but the
details are a little bit more
interesting we have a series of
satellites traveling above our heads
about 22,000 kilometers away
broadcasting a signal and the main part
of that signal is the time so if you
think of the satellite as a giant clock
in space about the size of a double
wardrobe with huge great wings either
sides or solar panels
that's what our satellites look like and
they're broadcasting 24/7 the time and
with that time signal they're also
broadcasting a little bit of information
about the health of the satellite
whether it's on the right little bit
whether its clock is as accurate as it
could be and they're constantly
comparing the time on the satellite
clock with a much more accurate saying
much more accurate another atomic clock
on on the ground which it will tell the
satellite that it's clocks are running
either slightly slow or slightly fast or
they're gaining X number of nanoseconds
a week or a year or or whatever and that
will be broadcast down to the receiver
and it will tell the receiver all the
information it needs now to be able to
calculate the time precisely it will
also add a little bit extra information
it will tell the the receiver where to
see and where to find the other
satellites in the constellation so that
once you've found one that will tell you
how far it is away from one particular
satellite imagined that in the middle of
here is a satellite and it's rod casting
the time the surface of the balloon is
an equidistant time from the satellite
we know because we've picked up the
signal that somewhere on
the surface of this balloon is us but
without a little bit more information we
could be anywhere
radius of tens of thousands of
kilometers perhaps so this is where it
all gets complicated because I need
about three hands but if we did it take
a second satellite broadcasting the time
I think I might just be able to manage
eh okay but we then have a circle of
intersection and I now know the time I'm
somewhere along that circle that's still
an awful lot of room to play with so I
asked another satellite to to tell me
the time and that satellite we interact
on a circle like that so now I know that
I could be either of those two places
still not very good because being in two
places at once doesn't really help
anyone so we take information from
another satellite and that will give us
one single point where I could be this
other point is probably thousands of
miles in outer space that is the way in
which we use the time signal from the
satellites to tell us exactly where we
are and if only it was as easy as that
it would be great you know I'm driving
on the motorway that's gonna be out of
date quite quickly that is refreshed
several times every second
then the refresh rate is about 50 times
a second so even if you're traveling
along a motorway in the jet fighter it
will keep up with you don't worry I've
mentioned we have an accurate time
coming from the satellite the satellite
is broadcasting on a radio wave which is
traveling at the speed of light over 22
thousand kilometers it's going to hit
you about point zero seven of a second
after it's released from the satellite
the satellite has accurate clocks you
don't if if you were able to stick an
atomic clock for around about 50 K into
your mobile phone you would be able to
compete with satellites for a cure
timing the trick is to make the
satellites share the time and make this
into an atomic accuracy clock if we want
to know the height the distance
east-west the distance north-south
that's three unknowns T unknowns three
simultaneous equations can solve it by
putting the fourth one in we get four
dimensions the fourth dimension being
time and so all of a sudden my GPS
receiver my phone
is showing the same level of nanosecond
precision their timing that the
satellites are we're pretty good at
working out what an orbit looks like and
even though the satellite is traveling
at about seven kilometers a second we
know where they are but even though we
think of space is fairly empty there are
influences that might knock that
satellite off its exact orbit